superlatives times chris uh coming out
of conference championship weekend i'll
give you the first crack well um you
know the doctor always said two rockets
up your butt is good but three is really
what you want and i'll go with the old
tyreke hill yeah i don't know why i'm
saying that but tyree kill again
yesterday yeah the best receiver
in the nfl the
number one weapon
in the league i i don't care what you
want to call him receiver weapon
whatever the hell it is when the balls
isn't in his hand in his hands watch out
and i just think that's what jumps out
to me more than anything and just we
haven't hit on that aspect a whole lot
but tyree kill what he brings to the
game not only stretching the defense but
you know plays like we saw on the 71
yard reception it's a you mentioned it
to start the show it's a four yard throw
over the middle you know then he turns
on the afterburners and then turns on
the other afterburner and then that
third one right that gives him the elite
speed and runs all the way across the
field and does all these special things
it's just uh for for as awesome as we
know mahomes is
it's just the tandem of hill and of
course kelsey are so special to go along
with it and it's really just the perfect
tandem of guys to go with that type of
quarterback and tyree kill even though
he's not the biggest and doesn't have
the best hands in football and is not a
greatest route runner in football
man i don't know you still give me the
first pick or one pick to take any
receiver in the game i'm i think i'm
going him first right now
at the nfl level you rarely see a player
make other professional athletes look
like the awkward kid on
to
the
schoolyard
best athlete in the class right but
that's what he did twisted guys around
they didn't know where they were going
they didn't know which way they were
looking they didn't know what to do
that's what that suddenness the speed
the acceleration everything he has
that's what that does to a defensive
back all right i'm gonna stay with that
same game because
uh patrick mahomes is the captain of the
toe
uh the
captain i thought he had the captain of
the toe he had the toe injury whatever
happened to his toe injury he they said
before the game he had a shoe that was a
half size larger he had a pad in it he
seemed fine to me he seemed like normal
patrick will holmes all that talk about
the concussion all that talk about the
toe is he going to be the same guy is he
going to be limping around these were
all legitimate points to make there was
a report yesterday morning that he
wasn't 100
because of the toe and maybe he didn't
have that same
explosion that that we've seen from the
past but he's same he's just still
patrick mahomes he's playing his game
he's doing his thing and in the playoffs
it's a higher level toe injury or not
concussion or not
it's just he's just incredible and
how many of these super bowls is he
going to get to we're talking about tom
brady in 10. this guy's 25 years old
and he's on number two
and even though the afc has a lot of
great teams
their ability to just find that switch
whenever they need to against great
teams and not just win but overpower
them was there a point yesterday after
the chiefs took the lead 14-9 chris
where you ever thought that she's not
gonna lose the game no i i i mean i was
really having a hard time thinking that
when it was nine nothing buffalo i kept
going i don't think there's a chance
unless maybe kansas city makes another
mistake here and like you know fumbles
the ball and then they go up some
miraculously 17 nothing but no you're
right and once it went to 14-9 it's just
the way the game looked you went wait
one team looks faster
one team looks
more physical
and they're the team that just won the
super bowl and they have patrick mahomes
so you just went nah they're not there's
no way buffalo is going to win it just
it never felt like it was a threat all
game long
by the way you didn't get my reference
captain of the toe is a seinfeld thing i
wasn't at the toes it's a seinfeld bit
and then sometimes the second toe grows
longer than the big toe oh right
i didn't remember that episode but i
figured it was some play on some you
know old obscure movie or something that
none of us have ever seen well first
it's an old not obscure tv show that was
thrust back into relevance over the
weekend for reasons completely unrelated
to seinfeld but go ahead okay well but
he was directly involved in it um
polish and confidence that's my next one
because that's what the old tom brady
did for the tampa bay buccaneers it's
like hey we knew bruce listen we were at
the super bowl last year and what
remember matt ryan oh he talked about we
did an interview all he talked about was
how good the bucks were the bucks i
don't know that might have been the best
defense we played last year the bucks
the bucks the bucks the bucks you know
there was something missing from that
team
tom brady came there
and
it's like
execution went up a little bit he's
gotten everybody on the same page a
little bit born adversity in the offense
and then you know he gave everybody in
the organization confidence it just
doesn't matter what game it is we got 12
we could we can win this game no matter
what it is he's clutch he's brady and he
did that to jump start that team
yesterday oh we're playing green bay and
aaron rodgers up in green bay they don't
lose oh don't worry the first few third
downs of the game i'll just throw
strikes and we'll move the ball down the
field loosen everybody up make us feel
like we belong and we can win this
football game and that's where brady is
amazing he's
i know i don't say he's the greatest of
all time he's the clutches of all time
i've never seen anybody better under
pressure in big moments whatever it is
he doesn't blink and he brought polish
and confidence that organization that
they've never had and that's why they're
in the super bowl yeah absolutely and it
was the perfect spot for him and it took
a while to make it work but they did and
that's my next one this is the
uh i had a good name for it and then i
kind of got twisted up in my brain
basically don't complain about a late
buy award because this was the perfect
year to have the latest possible buy
you'll hear teams say oh we got a bye
week week 12 week 10 week whatever oh
this year with no off season program
with no preseason games and you're
putting this new group together with tom
brady coming in to have a week 13 buy
after thanksgiving that's how late it
was it was the week after thanksgiving
week that they had their buy
they were seven and five going into
there by they are seven and oh
on the other side of their buy and
having that break when they had it the
opportunity to take a step back to
figure out what they're doing right what
they're doing wrong where they need to
improve what is coming for them december
football that was the big critique that
bruce arians had last year of jameis
winston
the inability to step up in the month of
december right they were seven and seven
it fell apart he had all the
interceptions he'd been with other
quarterbacks who stepped up in december
this team stepped up in december and it
stepped up even more in january three
straight road wins to get to the super
bowl which we they will get to play at
home yeah it's it's crazy it really is
home super bowl uh it's an amazing
accomplishment for the tampa bay
buccaneers yeah and and to put this team
together i don't care how good it was or
anything like that with no you know off
season otas all of that
and they consistently got better to
where hey again we saw it during the
year right there was many times a year
we were like man when the bucks are good
are they the best team in football i
mean we really we said that a number of
times then they'd have a game where
you'd go that looked ugly i don't know
what they are quite yet but we knew
their potential was big time and they
finally have reached it uh and it's
amazing to see it really is um
i think my next one
is gonna go to the
the forgotten unit award
um and that that's the chief secondary
uh another you know just a another part
of that team that sometimes goes under
the radar gets swept under the radar big
time yes yes uh because of all the
superstars there but yesterday you see
josh allen and that offense we heard
chris jones in a clip last week say they
remind me of our team a few years ago
they can score on anybody well the
chiefs defense just continues to rise to
challenges always oh you know last week
is stopping the two-headed monster
running game no problem this week it's
stopping you know one of the most
explosive right arms and best receiver
combos and football with digs and all
that they're on them like glue all game
long all game i'm playing man-to-man i
mean how many times did romo and nance
show clips last night of you know josh
allen's scrambling
and the play has been going on for five
seconds and nobody's still open nobody
you know so that chief secondary has
continued to get better you know when
you talk about breeland chavarrius ward
legeria sneed rashaan fetten thornhill
matthew sorenson man they got a lot of
good versatility there and a lot of good
players a lot of credit to that unit
that sometimes doesn't get the
credit it deserves yeah when you're on a
team with patrick mahomes and that
offense it's very easy for the defense
to be overlooked but they had to do
their part otherwise it was going to be
a shootout and they put the clamps on
buffalo after the nine-nothing start
they scored some points later once it
was it was it was just over at that
point but uh uh great balanced team and
they're gonna be very difficult to beat
in tampa bay last one for me the 268 for
268 award because i can't believe here
we are the day after the conference
championships have ended all 256 regular
games played regular season games played
in the 17 weeks they had to do a little
surgery to move some games around but
they got 256 in
as they were supposed to
all postseason games have gone off
without a hitch other than the brown
steelers game but the browns won that
game without their head coach on the
sidelines so the the pandemic has not
it's amazing to me when you consider how
bad it is the number of deaths right now
the stories that we see
about the communities that are still
ravaged by it how in the hell did the
nfl pull this off i think a lot of luck
was involved but also their ability to
pivot to be flexible and to have that
attitude that we know people are going
to get it but we're just going to have
protocols in place to keep it from
spreading once
they
they get it and they're tested positive
and they're still doughnut holes and
windows and opportunities for it to
spread they did a great job of keeping
it from spreading and now they got one
more game and the problem is they got
two weeks i'd really if i just want to
play this game i'd want to play this
game tonight if i was the nfl but uh i
i'm sure they would love to just play it
coming up this sunday because who knows
what's going to happen over the course
of the next two weeks do you think it's
like
an advantage or disadvantage for tampa
to be
there at this is it like a distraction
at all for you you know in like in your
mind when you think about them than
being at the super bowl site for the
next two weeks and the other team no
because there's nothing going to happen
i guess nothing's going to happen it's
not a super bowl site no i know i just i
guess people will be starting to go in
and you'll start to see the pageantry of
it all and
and it's not the same i'm not sure i'm
not sure i'm i think that you know
i'm sure we will still see images of
people doing things that they shouldn't
be doing like gathering in large crowds
but a lot of the traditional super bowl
stuff i'd say most of it if not all of
it is just not going to be part of this
and the chiefs are going to stay in
kansas city we reported this last month
the teams from out of the city are going
to treat it like a normal road game to
tampa now i think they'll let them come
no earlier than friday right uh to tampa
but yeah the bucks
they'll be staying at home all week
they're keeping them in their normal
routine at their facility go home
no hotel stays and they're just going to
trust that what they've done all season
long is going to work and look if you
regardless of how seriously or not a
team took the protocols throughout the
regular season
now is the time when you're down to two
teams where it's on everyone all the
team leaders do you think tom brady's
not gonna wear out everyone on that
roster to make sure they go straight
home into a room seal the door and stay
there until the time comes to go to work
the next morning yeah i would think
everybody is there's comments made after
the game to be extra careful do all that
you're right i mean there's super bowl
trophy rings legacies they're all on the
line here for both of these teams and i
think both of these teams are the type
of teams that realize it want it
understand their own legacies around it
and all that too so i i i don't expect
to hear anything bad at least knock on
wood i hope not when the buccaneers had
their late bye that was one of the first
things bruce arians expressed concern
about that bye week creating
opportunities for guys to get infected
so they've been there not that long ago
and they just slip back into that mode
and hope that it all works out and you
know every team's been stung by it at
one point or another except the seahawks
i believe but they got every reason to
button it up over the course of the next
13 days
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports